thrown back by the rapid ukrainian
offensive in the kharkiv region east of
ukraine the russians are going to have
to dig in somewhere and now we can begin
to see where
they're certainly making a stand at
svetova east of the oscar river now this
is really important to them because
svetov controls the last good supply
route from belgarot in russia to their
forces further south
but the ukrainians are now in a position
to attack the p-66 highway that runs
south from
tove towards cremena on the northern
doorstep of the donbass so the russians
are also trying hard to regain their
positions at cremena because if they
can't then alicia shan's conservation
remember them could be surrounded from
the north
so the next phase of this battle in the
northeast is now beginning to take shape
in the southwest the battle for cursing
continues now cursing is the more
important strategic objective and
russian troops are fighting hard to
retain it
it appears that the ukrainians are
working to squeeze russian forces
elsewhere in the region back into the
city itself
and then they'll probably be trying to
wear them down
now russia's response to these setbacks
has been to launch more rocket attacks
against civilian targets and
infrastructure
the dam and the hydroelectric plants are
kiviri they were attacked repeatedly now
there is military logic in this for
russia breaking the dam floods the
inhulits river and that destroys some of
the pontoon bridges the ukrainians
depend on now that they've crossed the
inulits
the dam is rapidly repaired the pontoons
are replaced and russian attacks on the
dam will probably continue
it's all part of the battle of logistics
without which frontline battles will
always fail
when it comes to logistics and support
some of the headline figures are pretty
dramatic
the russians have lost over 6 000 pieces
of
significant
military equipment ukrainians only about
a quarter of that figure
but those big russian losses are still
generally small in terms of the amount
of equipment they have available whereas
ukrainian losses are a bigger proportion
of what they can ultimately throw into
the battle
which emphasizes two fundamental issues
one is that ukraine will need western
military equipment for as long as it
fights this war
and two
that means we're witnessing the return
of industrial scale warfare to europe
for the first time
in a couple of generations